hey Samuel lead see I hope you're good
it's the beginning of the year and I am
in sunny Florida absolutely beautiful
the reason I've come to Florida is
because it's a different time zone and
it's a really good opportunity to just
come recharge your batteries plan the
year without any distractions so your
phone's not gonna be pinging or going
off and I'm saying at this house and
inside there there's about 50 people in
there mostly who are millionaires and
multimillionaires we've even got some
billionaires in the house so not only am
i recharging my batteries and thinking
and planning the year but also we're
having a mastermind with brainstorming
ideas and it just is absolutely
fantastic so I'd encourage you whatever
line of work you're in whether it's in
property business give yourself time to
think and I often find that when I do
nothing I get a lot more done than when
I'm really busy because the ideas that
come up it's just incredible so I'll
share a little bit around this guy okay
hey ladies how's it going and some of
these guys are actually from England so
yeah I'm gonna go for debt stunning
views are we going pictures right now no
is your camera high it's always
dangerous whenever I leave England
because I uh if I ever go somewhere
really nice I just want to immigrate
there however my mission is in England
and you know what there's the
opportunities the investment
opportunities I just don't think you can
be England
even though as beautiful as it is here
baby
so just arrived at the airport about to
go back to England Manchester really
excited to see him my family again and I
think my number one lesson from from
this week has got to be that if you want
to be successful it's about who you hang
around with that is the biggest thing
I've learned this week hang around
successful people you will be successful
hang on millionaires you'll be a
millionaire hang around with
billionaires you'll be a billionaire and
that's what has made me jump on flights
and I'm just flying back to England and
then a day after I'm going to Ireland to
meet Richard Branson so just get around
the right people hope that's helpful
kind of cool that in a couple of days of
me in this guy in person
have yourself an awesome week and let me
know in the comments below what lesson
you found most helpful